[Music]
Christel you literally like lost her
mind an explosive moment on The Bachelor
women tell all special never-before-seen
footage of villain crystal was aired in
it she slams Ahri and her fellow women
the insults were intense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we saw some footage tonight that we
hadn't seen before of some names you
called are in the other women did you
remember that what was your I did not
know you owned that do you apologize for
that what are you what yeah you don't
wanna say it it's just I was having an
intimate conversation that was caught
through the peeping tom of my hotel room
when I'm in the bathroom that was caught
through the room I was just really upset
and hurt man I was just like I felt it
my teammates I were very disrespected
and I felt that we should take a stand
and show re the him pulling back his
word him dangling a carrot for us to
dance and perform and then pulled it
away it's not okay with me
and I would never tolerate that in the
real world
[Music]